well this may be the strangest year in
the lifetime of anyone still breathing
2020 but it could get even stranger it
turns out that chaos here on earth has
not brought an end to unusual sights
above us in the sky last week in
California an eyewitness observed about
a hundred small white orbs hovering
above where they balloons Birds
something more we don't know we might
know more if we had more information
from the Pentagon they've been studying
UFOs carefully for more than a decade
but even now they are keeping what they
are finding to themselves and themselves
only there appears to be no systematic
sharing of intelligence between the
Pentagon and our intelligence agencies
and that's very odd at least conceivably
UFOs may not be from space know what the
Pentagon believes this they think they
are from space but at least within the
realm of possibility they could be from
China or another one of this country's
enemies so we should find out this week
the Senate Intelligence Committee took a
step toward fixing that they voted to
require the Defense Department to
compile and release a detailed report
explaining everything it knows about
unexplained aerial phenomena we hope
that happens we have no faith that it
actually will but we are rooting for it
and of course if and when that report
does come out you will hear about it
here first for many years you've heard
people say oh it's just UFO craziness
that was our position too but it's not
all craziness there are things we don't
know and we also know that our
authorities enthusiastically lie to us
so it's worth pressing them because